thank you
[Music]
all right there's a Belgian man love it
already who faked his own death you've
probably seen this somewhere but this
guy faked his own death right
ends up they they those whole funeral
for the guy
family friends they all go they got this
funeral going they believe this man is
dead even his like kids half believe it
I think or something like that in the
middle of the ceremony of the funeral
procession a helicopter comes flying in
and the dude comes out of the helicopter
and is like I'm not dead and everyone
comes and hugs him he did it to teach a
lesson to his family
about what he felt like they didn't pay
enough attention to it dude this guy's
the [__] wow right I love it he what is
he a 12 year old girl he complains that
they were being [__] under
appreciative of him and that he wanted
to teach them a lesson that like oh like
if someone leaves and then you start
feeling sad like it's gonna be too late
so is it like a father that has
ungrateful children no no
it was like I think the family was in a
direct like her like the daughter
actually posted on social media that
stuff to play into them he says that he
half told the kids but people also don't
believe that it's true
he must that's so crazy that he came in
at a helicopter I know yeah all right
all right I'm gonna defend him real
quick if he is Rich this is probably
he's he's looked upon as a bank account
so his whole family just uses him for
money and he doesn't really say no and
all this stuff and then after a while
he's like you know what these
[__] take me for granted
imagine if your bank account just
disappeared which is me I'm your bank
account yeah but then they're they're
leaving it there's a way
they're like cousins and extended
relatives they're not gonna get the will
like they're like his own children so
then like but they get the alive money
when he's alive yeah so what if he feels
like he's just being taken advantage of
they don't really care about him they
only come around when they need money so
he says I'll show you [__]
what's really important it's a good
strategy yeah there should be a service
that actually does this for other people
you want you want to know the ironic
thing so like his whole thing is that he
feels like they're nobody's uh
they're not inviting into things he's
trying to talk to them they don't talk
to him man I try to help man
the funny thing is is that only half the
people that were invited even showed up
to the funeral wow
even as he died
nobody can I hope you guys learned their
lesson dude as he's repelling
no one's here
a guy that does something like that
sounds obnoxious though yeah he had a
film he hired a film crew to like do it
dude dude as he's repelling down he sees
half the seats are empty he's like what
the [__] it's like did I come in an hour
early
I know who my date was
[__] you guys
that's like total narcissism to the
highest degree right that's big budget
narcissist because I feel like if you
affected a lot of lives in a positive
way and they love you they're gonna show
up
yeah people go out of their way to
[__] show up look at Michael
Jackson's funeral you saw the whole
world came and he did a lot of bad stuff
no he didn't he did
allegedly yeah
I love that yeah you're a lot of [__]
haters but did you see it on opposite
sides of that argument
but the whole world
the whole world
allegedly I'm sorry oh you mean bad
isn't cool yeah yeah that isn't good
yeah like because 1990s that's nice
do you don't you feel like if somebody
did that to you let's say you had a
relative that pulled this stunt wouldn't
you not like him more often yeah yeah I
[__] hate their guts yeah but it
depends how cool he repelled down
and then he died
but like don't you realize that he can
never truly be dead after this because
no one will believe it now
yeah you'd have to see yeah everyone
would show up to the morgue and no one
would go to the funeral or they get the
guy from like like any martial arts
movie that's a tournament and he checks
his pulse and he's like
he's like
like holy [__] this is official dude and
then everyone turns their backs
it's a disgrace
you have any gold teeth
yeah at least fake your death using the
Bloodsport plot but yeah it doesn't seem
like maybe indulging things work
differently and people actually regret
under appreciating this man I have no
idea he just sounds like a [__]
narcissist yeah
yeah you don't invite me to your party
yeah you're gonna be sorry like if you
didn't get invited people just don't
like you he's like a runaway crying kind
of vibe you know like when people
you're not chasing me right you're not
chasing me
I'm here guys I'm it I was like no it's
okay
I'm doing some [__] like this you think
your mom would do that my mom has weird
antics
like my mom uh when when I got kicked
out of uh High School for the first time
I was living with my dad
my mom let me uh borrow her car
and then one day I came out it was a
Honda CRV I came out what the [__]
where's the car and then I called my mom
oh no my my car got stolen and she goes
I stole it
what happened and so I found out
she's been going to the house like on
Sundays in the morning to look at the
mileage
and he said why are you driving a
thousand miles a week huh and then so
she just came like so she always is up
to crazy Antics all the time so I could
picture her doing like oh my son doesn't
think he left me well I'm gonna die in
front of him you know what's funny
though to be fair to be fair your mom's
Antics are counter Antics to your antics
oh yeah that's true probably wouldn't
need to do any of those yeah
it's not driven by narcissism it's just
defense
dude he cracked the case
and also does she really sound like that
that's her actual voice
[Laughter]
holy [__] do you think she would ever
come on JK oh I wanted to so bad that's
one of the most requested guests we
gotta get around I'll bring her on she's
gonna uh move back to Monterey Park and
when she does when she does I'll bring
her on [__] yeah and then we gotta have
a dance segment a dance segment yeah she
loves dancing
like
and you guys have a battle
she smokes you guys if that's what it
takes to bring her in that's what we're
doing man but just starts having music
and then she just starts going yeah
she's got moves dude my mom is one of
the craziest ladies I know though
interesting she sounds like it she's
really fun does she think you're pretty
crazy
I think she thinks I'm crazy and I think
she's crazy
balance each other out I feel like your
mom
looks down upon the world like they just
don't know yeah the stuff that she knows
I feel like when you tell us stories
like how you're at the massage place and
you set fire that's my favorite story of
course she thinks you're crazy you set
fire to a massage table she can't
predict though oh you know what though
now I can't since you brought that up it
was experimentation for sure but I can't
wait for you to tell your story and then
hear her rebuttal like herself if she
remembers yeah oh yeah that's true
because she doesn't remember a lot of
[__] so we just had um uh we just had uh
dinner at IHOP the other day and then we
were talking about like birthdays and
stuff and then um she was like
she was bringing I was like oh man I
can't believe like my son's almost 40 or
whatever and then I started bringing up
like past memories and then I was like
Hey Mama you remember
um
for all of my birthdays you wanted me to
get on my knees and bow to you every
morning and thank you for birthing me
and my mom almost spit her [__]
coffee out she's like what
that's that's crazy I'm like no you did
that you forgot an annual thing my
birthday it was about how I can serve
her but she forgot right and then I was
like okay hold up forget these crazy
things are you crazy ass [__] I'm gonna
[__] remind you of this [__] did she
do this all of them no and then I was
like are you [__] crazy [__] you
don't remember [__] I was like do you
remember I got receipts I was like do
you remember on my birthday you put your
name on the birthday cake and she goes
what that's [__] crazy and then you
found a picture and then I was like okay
okay I'm so glad we're here right now
the race
three seats and I showed her this
happy birthday and it says Langley and
Barton on there
and she's like I never saw her eyes open
so big like she's like I know this
Bakery
yeah she was like
what who made that cake I was like you
got that cake
because my birthday is about serving her
so it would be cool don't even remember
this philosophy no no can you just
forget a philosophy that you've had for
the last 10 [__] 15 years yeah so it
would be cool to hear her perspective on
the burning of the chiropractor place
and she even remembers that's a great
story I heard a chiropractor Place for
no reason I was like fine what kind of
experience oh